bonsoir 4 car le conseil d'état qui a
donc tranché et pas vraiment en faveur
du ministère de l'intérieur
oui en effet le conseil d'état a annulé
plusieurs dispositions polémique du
schéma national du maintien de l'ordre
ce texte avait été publié le 16
septembre 2020 par le ministre de
l'intérieur il est dicté des règles et
conduite à tenir pour les forces de
l'ordre cours des manifestations
et bien ce texte avait fortement déplu
donc le conseil d'état avait été saisi
par des associations comme la ligue des
droits de l'homme ou encore des
syndicats comme le syndicat national des
journalistes ou la cgt qui conteste
évidemment ces dispositions
et pour commencer donc les sages ont
annulé la disposition sur la nasse un
élément très important du maintien de
l'ordre dans les manifestations
le conseil d'état estime qu'elle est
susceptible d'affecter significativement
la liberté de manifester et la liberté
d'aller et venir et katia les autres
dispositions annulées concerne notre
profession justement les journalistes
et oui tout à fait par exemple l'ordre
donné aux journalistes de se disperser à
la fin des manifestations et bien en
même temps à d'ailleurs que les autres
manifestants et pour les sages les
journalistes doivent pouvoir continuer
d'exercer librement leur mission
d'information sauf bien sûr s'il font
obstacle aux forces de l'ordre c'est
rarement le cas en l'occurrence sur le
terrain il n'est plus question de leur
imposer non plus des conditions au port
de protections dernier point une
disposition qui avait beaucoup ému notre
profession l'obligation de s'accréditer
pour être mise en relation avec le canal
d'information en temps réel mise en
place lors des manifestations et bien
cette disposition aussi été annulé et
quatre salles le ministère de
l'intérieur a réagi
oui en effet alors le ministère je vais
le citer a réagi en disant que
d'émotivité des modifications pardon
seront apportées pour permettre
d'atteindre les objectifs voulus par le
texte tout en respectant les
orientations de la décision du conseil
d'état
en outre le ministère s'est réjoui que
la très grande majorité du texte ait été
validé par les sages à propos de la
technique de la nasse le conseil d'état
avait jugé que les conditions d'emploi
de cette technique d'encerclement
devaient être précisés
alors le ministère a rétorqué qu'il
allait s'y employer parce que évidemment
là cette technique
cette pratique très employé bien doit
être maintenu dans leur idée et puis au
sujet des journalistes le ministère a
donné le ton il a réitéré cette
distinction entre les journalistes ils
ont avec cartes et les journalistes ce
qui semble être plutôt les journalistes
street les journalistes militants il a
commenté chaque phase des sages
sous-entendant que l'idée d'encadrer
l'information qui ne pourrait être donné
à tous tous sans condition et est
toujours bien présente
merci quatre techniques en direct du
conseil d'état